to reduce the spread of the coronavirus
many Europeans simply need to stay at
home we cannot move around meet and
socialize as a result people tell work
and spend much time online
unfortunately criminals take advantage
of this they follow us online and
exploit our concerns about the
coronavirus our fear becomes their
business opportunity according to our
European Union agencies the amount of
cybercrime in the European Union has
increased and the number of fake
medicines disinfection sprays a miracle
cures sold online is staggering the
medical products most often offered
online these days are counterfeit
surgical masks we work with the national
governments and the European Union
agencies to address this and to keep
people safe our police cooperation
agency Europol has supported in the past
weeks a global operation against
trafficking in counterfeit medicines as
a result of this operation more than 4.4
million units of illicit pharmaceuticals
were seized worldwide 37 organized crime
groups were dismantled 121 arrests were
made and 2,500 links website social
media online marketplaces adverts were
taken down 90 countries took part in the
operation it is important to be prepared
our European Union Agency provide advice
about how you can protect yourself
please check where the websites are
really maintained by a trustworthy
entity do not install applications that
promise to track your symptoms or the
spread of the virus think twice what
medicine you buy online and where it
comes from if a vaccine against the
corona virus is developed your
government and
institutions in general will announce it
you will know about it from trustworthy
sources until then we will continue
working closely with the national
governments with the help of our
agencies to keep counterfeit medicine
out of your way